one two three four five six
my name is Lilith Nachum owner and
administrator of [ __ ] alone [ __ ] alone
basically means house of peace and it's
rcfe residential care facility for the
elderly you see people that have been
professors at UCLA doctors pilots and
all of a sudden they can't walk they
forget their name it's hard to watch it
to know that it's just a matter of time
before I get there before my mother gets
there before my grandmother gets there
it's been a few years of a lot of
reality checks on a daily basis so this
second facility is just down the block
from our first place this house has been
a big blessing for us my mother-in-law
that very very sick that wanted to bring
her here so in order for me to bring her
here I had to has a facility with the
right staff with the right caregivers
and I got my license
two weeks later she passed away so this
is like the memory of my mother-in-law
and also it's been a big blessing for
all of us how are you mama how is
everything
most things are okay good good I'm happy
so basically we have 24 clients one of
them is Elsie she does beets flowers and
beautiful art taking care of the elderly
is very rewarding especially when they
improve some of them come here and they
are quite frail and I see how they
progressed and they actually become
healthier participate for how are you
how is everything
we also have another client her name is
Lou Ella when she first moved into our
place she was not able to walk or talk
or eat even now thank God she's eating
walking and talking and she's so happy
what letter is this one
that's right and this one is in
afternoon basically we do bingo puzzles
arts and crafts because it's very good
for the cognitive skills how to pH D
etat Washington State and then a UCLA
retired professor from there if you're
not used to living in of institutional
care it's adjustment it would be good to
have more younger people have some
experience with facilities like this
can you put H back where is age no no no
don't eat the challenge in this job is
when people decline and you actually see
how they deteriorate if you find
yourself being really helpless let's get
them out and then are going also today
they have a special treat you're gonna
have dinner
the comida y know dinner
I feel the elderly are selected a lot by
their own families and it's safe because
LT kind of wants to have their own
family around I have some family members
who don't even visit and that's the sad
part
and sometime we try to call them to
speak to them they don't even answer the
phone
[Music]
that's one of the things like you know
it really hurt me deep inside just take
the moment and come and visit your
parents if it was the other way around
the your parents will come and visit you
one parent could take care of ten kids
ten kids cannot take care of one parent
when I was living on my own I used to
celebrate the holidays and I would
always call up nursing homes and ask
them to please send me a few of their
people so that their people could then
enjoy the holidays to their fullest and
not spend it lonely in a room by
themselves pleased remember the elders
because they have contributed so much to
all of our lives I had a client and I
had asked them so then is there anything
that you need do you want me to do
anything for you is there any food you
want me to pick up for you and he said
no just please if you could come and
talk to me
[Music]
just visit your grandparents visit your
aunt who's 90 years old who's home by
herself with a caregiver and have a
conversation with them spend 10 to 15
minutes with them and you will see how
much they thrive there is a beautiful
beautiful Psalm in the Book of Psalms
which King David wrote that says in
Hebrew especially hey Neela it Cigna
which translates to don't cast me away
at old age and when I lose my strength
and my ability don't let me go and I
live by that sentence it's meant for our
parents and for our loved ones when they
get old to not throw them away to not
cast them away to not let go but to be
there for them especially in the last
years of their lives to nurture them to
take care of them
and when it's your time people will do
the same for you
[Music]